so again this is a phenomenal property  we've just been blown away  from the lobby to the casino floor to  the sports book  the restaurant road that we got there  some famous street eats and look at this  louis pup  i can take him home right i need this in  my living room  well you can come check it out when they  finally open tomorrow we know it's going  to be a huge grand weekend grand party  tomorrow  and we got you covered so tune in keep  it locked to channel 8 because we're  going to show you an inside look  all the way until tomorrow it's going to  be amazing you guys back to you in the  studio  so wait a second bianca you're going to  bet with other people's money and you're  going to take the louis vuitton dog with  you  yes okay yes i mean is there any other  way  john i'm not i'm not complaining come  over here so i can use some of your  coins  i'll join you and we can spend john's  money thank you  short time at the table if that happens  thanks bianca